words about automet because I want to
get to the uh the recursion part
recursive part right so one issue with
the uh autom is that uh as we we seen as
we discussed before it can explode so if
we have assortativity and commutativity
which basically happens whenever you
have any language uh so you can have a
really large automaton uh and then if we
also want to extract a dag instead of a
tree and even if we just want to extract
a tree the cost of exraction is
proportional uh to the uh to the size of
the tree uh and it can be even you know
Pol normal or exponential in the side of
tree if we go go to the route of uh you
know the fix ILP or if we do do uh an
programming so it's really important
that we want to uh maybe after growing
the tree want to make it smaller uh to
speed up exraction so if we think about
automaton and then think about wanting
to make it smaller there's a word called
automaton minimiz Iz ation uh that was
really well studied is part maybe part
of the intro class intro Theory class
about how to take a DFA and then
minimize it right and then so similar
things are also our study for tree
automa uh and then we actually try out
the idea uh to say if can we can we take
a Tre automaton and then minimize it so
that we can make expression faster and
and it worked pretty well right so to
some extent so one uh small Improvement
is that even if we after even if we if
we minimize automaton uh if the the uh
exponen number of permutation of say
multiplication uh is still not merged so
we still have a really large automaton
and there's really no reason to
explicitly represent all the
permutations so what we are looking at
right now is that can we do some notion
of automat minimization module of these
equivalences to further shrink the size
of the autom so that's one of the the
research project which we're working on
right now
assignments yes does that take the cost
function into account or it's just
symbol for yeah so uh let's see uh let's
say no yeah so the the extraction part
takes takes care of the cost
function so with this method you recover
kind of classic optimization
technique like out the
loop something more a little formal for
this class of of optimization you know
equality saturation can be cover yeah so
uh so there are maybe two different
results which is that if we have a set
of R RS that's complete uh which means
that it's able to prove any true
identities uh then in theory given
infinite time and space we can you know
discover any alization that uh that's
anty and then a little bit more
practical is that uh if your proof uh
proof size uh is less than n then equ
Satur equ saturation will discover that
that program within any any
iterations and then the hope is that the
graph doesn't explode within any
iterations so sometime it does so that's
also a a real
challenge okay so now let's switch gears
uh into recursive uh programs and then
so this is stuff I learned while working
with Mahmud H Reinhard and Dan so thanks
to them for for teaching me this the
work and then this is mostly work done
by uh esparza's group so I think Esparza
will also visit this program in the
future but it's it's helpful to Rin and
repeat just to make sure people
understand okay so another goal for for
this program is said at the end of
program everyone will be able to write
datalog so I'm going to introduce the
datalog syntax one more time uh and here
is the conjuncted cury we see right this
is non-recursive dat log and then we
just say that in the first rule we say
that the twole XYZ is in R if we have XY
in the in E and then T and Y Z in t
right so this how how to read the uh one
single rule and then we can also project
things away and then that just means
that you know you compute the same r and
then you throw away the Y attribute and
then make it into set by D duplicating
so the example down here is that given
that we have inputs T and E which are
both uh you know this table uh which is
visualized by by this graph uh then the
r relation we're going to get uh uh what
we're going to get is is going to be one
two three uh 2 three 4 and 34 five and
the es relation we just project away the
Y column to get 1 3 two four and 3 five
okay and then to make it recursive we
basically just you know put uh an atom
in the body item in the head as well so
here we have the world simplest
recursive data program so in the base
case we say that everything is that's in
the edge relation we say that is in the
transit closure of the graph and in the
rec case say that if we have an edge
between X and Y uh and y and z are in
the transit closure uh then we also put
X in trans closure so here we're just
Computing trans closure of the
graph the way we do it the way we
evaluate program is that we start by
assigning all of the recursive at
relations to Mt so here T start t0o
starts as mty and then if a relation
doesn't appear in the head we say it's
an input relation so e just Rel constant
that's always
this and every iteration will F fire
every single rule and then add a result
into the the H relation so in the first
Iration we fire the first rule and then
we see that uh T t0 was empty so we add
everything from E into t0 and then the
second rule says that you know we join e
with t and add result because t0 was
empty there's nothing to join um so this
rule produces uh nothing in the first
right so in the first we just add uh the
E relation s is into the T relation
in the second iteration it gets a little
more interesting so we look at the first
rule it still uh still says that move
everything to from E into T so we
already did that uh it doesn't change
anymore uh and then the second rule now
fires because T T1 is now non empty so
we will join e with T1 and then add a
result back into to T itself so uh this
is the same joint we saw on the last
slide uh so we just add these three
tupos 1 3 two four 35 into t uh and then
by the end of the second interation uh
the T relation contains uh all of these
two poles and at this point the cation
doesn't add any anything anything new so
we converge and
stop okay uh so now we're gonna twist uh
our understanding of of this specture a
little bit uh into into linear algebra
because everything is linear algebra so
there's internet about that so one
important uh uh concept is is actually
domain of the database so these are
simply all of the values that we see in
the table so here we have one two three
four three four
five uh and then so once we have the AC
domain we can have this kind of a uh uh
bit ventor encoding of any relation
using the active domain so we simply
just take the C product of our act
domain so we have one one one two 1 314
and then we have a one entry uh for
places where there there is a tle right
so here is a one two twole in the
Elation so we have uh one over here for
one two uh and then there's no one three
so we have zero over here there was also
no one one we have zero over there uh
and then we do this uh for basically uh
all possible positions that we can get
from from the AC domain and then in this
way we can essentially represent the
Elation as this big
Vector right and then the length of the
big big Vector will be 25 so does this
make sense for
everybody okay uh so now we represent
like this and we can essentially think
of the uh our data program now as
applying a function f onto this B bit
Vector which represents uh the the state
of the tation at each step until a fixed
point so now the the function f is a
function that Maps a 25 Dimension bit
VOR into a new 25 di Dimension bit VOR
right and then we can generalize this a
little more right so we were working
with the the saring of of buan before
and we generally this to work over the
sumary of reals or sumary of tropical
numbers we can encode more uh
interesting programs maybe like Matrix
uh multiplication and then we have also
shortest path programs so we can encode
it encode it like this and then in
general the goal of De out evaluation is
to find a fixed Point uh for the
function f right such that F applying f
one more time to the fix point doesn't
change
it yeah and then uh so one important
part is that in this talk we're dealing
with a particular kind of saring that's
called a close saring uh so it uh s all
of the usual identity of the Samar ring
of of any Samar ring so we have
associativity of AD
commutativity zero identity one identity
uh and then the special thing is the
last one so this is a one to pay
attention attention to so we defined
this closure operator that has the
property such that 1 plus a times the
closure of a is the same as closure of a
so think of this as a clean Star right
so if you uh add one and if you multiply
you know you know the clean Star by the
same letter and then you add one to it
uh you get get by the same thing so
essentially uh you can think of this
star as the clean sequence where you
have 1 plus a plus a times a plus a * a
times a all the way uh at
Infinity yeah you understand why we're
doing the one plus
part uh yeah in in the in a future slide
yes yeah and then so this this is a a
really nice paper it's by by Leman in 77
uh that really cleanly characterz uh
these uh these
closings so going back to deog
evaluation so our goal is to find the
fix point of some uh some Vector
function f right and then the standard
implementation is the so-call naive
evaluation also called clean iteration
and literally we just you know apply F
to empty and then again again again and
again until we converge right so this is
uh the standard way it's really uh it's
actually pretty efficient because we can
really paralyze it vectorize it so it
actually can have very really efficient
implementation uh but actually we're GNA
use math to to do some magic to make it
faster and then we're gonna uh get help
from our or friends gaus and Newton uh
so this is also from the really
beautiful paper from Leman uh and then
the first paragraph I just really like
it uh so I'm going to read it really
quickly uh and then he said the war's
algorithm for computing the trans
closure of a BL Matrix flu algorithm to
Min minimum cost pass and CLE clean is
proof that every rular language can be
defined by rular expression and gaus
Jordan's method for inverting real
matrices are the same thing right so
this uh this uh different algorithms
from this very diverse set of discri
actually can be unified under the same
framework and that's exactly what we
Meed in this in this
paper um so yeah so this uh maybe this
is a start of answering like why do we
add one to the to the star right so if
you look at this uh uh this DEA program
where essentially multiplying e to
itself if we think of e as a matrix
right so you we're essentially uh
multiplying it with with itself and then
you adding the result into the previous
interation right so in the beginning we
have just one single e so that's where
we started from uh and then so that's
basically the the right so we start with
E and then the second regation computes
the two paths which is e times e and
third computes the three path so that's
e to the thir um and then so if we do
this until convergence we can Factor our
one e and then we see that here's our
sequence right so uh the identity plus e
plus e time C all the way to the to the
finish and then by definition of our
clean star uh this can be written as the
as a closure of e so this is all kind of
informal uh to to formalize it uh we can
look into paper and then there's
actually a precise way to understand
this so now let's prove that this e star
we use by abusing notation actually
satisfy uh this property uh that's
prescribed by the close summary okay so
we want to prove that 1 plus etimes e
remember es Matrix equals to e right so
we just start by expanding it e is by
definition uh over there it's 1 plus C
plus e time C all the way to the right
uh and then we can once again uh push
this distribute uh this uh this uh
multiplication across the process so now
we get that I plus e plus etimes Z all
the way to the uh to the finish and this
gets uh gets back e Star as we expected
you don't need any fin for this sequence
rather or
anything uh I believe not okay yeah you
don't need something to say this is
welled or something like that yes he
does so you said that you're going to
use math yes said that yeah
that three line thing yes that's not a
proof this
one yeah uh let's
see but why is it not proof because it
imply it for example you need to know
that that that sum is well defined it's
an infinite sum know that multiplication
is distributes over those infinite SS
whole bunch of things that you need to
know and you can only prove them if you
have some extra structure
there and you were going to talk about
that extra structure the oring structure
and things like that yeah so uh so let's
talk about it during discussion so I I
didn't prepare to go that go go to that
that much uh but I agree that's that's
important for math
disappoint okay uh so I'm sorry for gos
but uh let's make him happy in in the
afternoon okay so uh so here's right so
we want to solve for this uh uh to
actually solve for this uh this closure
without actually Computing the PO
potentially infinite sequence we're
going to uh uh we just use Clean
cleaning iteration to compute it uh so
back to the paper uh the claim is that
we can use the Floyd Mar cleaning
algorithm which was used for you know
generating compiling rejects into to uh
uh into automon and then finding
shortage pass to compute this closure
expression and here's really the really
simple algorithm uh and let's just
specialize it into the case of regular
inspection to help our understanding uh
so we just have uh some arbitrary
ordering of this of the states in the in
the automaton right so we talk about
automat in in the pr s so we assign
these indices to the automaton uh and
then this is our result this is the
Matrix we're going we're going to start
St our result in where the autom we're
going to store our result in so we
initialize with
empty uh and then for every state every
pair of States uh from one to n uh we're
going to uh look at the previous uh
previous automon and then try to find uh
whatever uh whatever whatever States we
have and then we have alternation that
we find find the states find autom that
goes from I to K and then K2 itself and
k2j right so we do this for every pair
and then we do this Loop for every K and
this is basically lets us construct the
the final atomicon that Rec recognizes
the the reg expression and then
similarly we can think of shortage path
so here to find the shortage path from
i2j so we either take the previous short
pass from i2j or find another short path
from i2k and K2 itself so here here in
the shortest pth case this is just empty
right with a with positive ways and then
k2j uh so this is a really simple
algorithm to uh to solve this uh uh
algebra path problem actually uh so this
takes an cubic time uh and then in
certain cases okay so an improved
algorithm is actually they call the ging
elimination which is a bit of a stretch
uh but it basically adds a little more
back back substitution into the into the
algorithm right so this is a pretty good
paper to to read about the the theory
and
practice uh and then in certain cases uh
uh actually inspired by program analysis
in programing languages we can do this
uh instead of cubic time we can do this
in nearly linear time right so so this
is a paper by targon saying that uh for
certain graphs that are called reducible
uh we can discuss more what that means
uh we can compute
the closure operation in M basically
linear time to the number of edges and
so this is a reverse acement function so
for this reducible
graphs can you tell us what these graphs
are what this whated means Yeah so
basically uh the reduction of a graph
you can do two things so if there's a
self Loop you delete a loop and then if
multiple uh if uh if one vertex uh has
multiple
edges kind of com to it but all of those
edges come from the same parent you can
kind of retract that edge so if you
retract this uh until you cannot anymore
and you get it you get back a single
vertex so that's called
reducible okay yeah about
mops right uh yes and then there I think
there's a way to generalize just to uh
just to regular graphs as well um but um
yeah so I have an example I need looking
for that's not reducible uh that that
can that we can look at in the
afternoon uh okay so another cool thing
is that we can actually compute uh
Matrix inversion with this closure
operation right and here's a proof uh I
guess proof now uh so so first of all uh
we basically want to prove that uh the
the inverse of B uh is equal to Identity
uh and then we start like this so we
Define it like this so we have I minus B
the closure of I minus B times B and
then we just change variable right we
call I minus b a uh to get get to the
second line uh and then we distribute uh
to get to the third line uh and then by
definition a star is one plus uh um uh a
star time a uh and then and then we we
get it over there right so by just
rearranging this uh this equation uh but
we get this equation to to
there you operation you are under semi
right so yeah so this is uh the case
where you have a ring so so this only
works where where you have say like real
numbers it doesn't work for
S okay so the takeway here is that we
can use uh this uh FL work show short
pth algorithm or G elimination to
compute the closure for linear data law
program in Cubit time uh and that's
actually pretty cool because we uh
before before this we didn't really have
any runtime guarantee of of recursive
program in general because we don't know
how long it takes to converge but here
we have this really simple algorithm
that give give us cubic time convergence
which is pretty nice and sometimes we
have a we have linear time if the graph
is
reducible okay so yeah so here what is
your input to your linear algorith is it
so what can you go the slide so what
tell us what's exactly the statement so
you're giving us
a which is a matrix right and then you
can do it inic time and in the dimension
of the Matrix right uh in the uh in the
size of the
Matrix squ right but you say you can
right uh I I think it's a size but I I
need to check on this yeah model the
number of vertices of the
gra see so so it is that Dimension and I
see okay so so yeah Dimension
yeah yeah so but this is really only res
to to linear datw program so what this
means that uh in the DAT in the datw
rule we are only allowed to join a
recursive relation with a non-recursive
relation so in our trans closure example
we joined e with T so that's linear
that's okay that's that we can handle
but if we have nonlinear programs maybe
we join a recursive R relation with a t
relation uh this this algorithm doesn't
doesn't support that so for that we need
to go to uh Newton uh Newton meod and
then uh I guess I have 10 more
minutes okay so uh really going back to
to this picture uh the standard way of
evaluating data program is is by naive
iteration so we just apply F until it
stop changing uh and then if we look at
uh General kind of uh numerical analysis
we know that another way to find a fix
point is uh is by taking uh a linear
approximation at some point and then uh
step step using the derivative uh in
there and and then the the the chances
are this takes fewer iteration to
converge uh than the than the naive
iteration so uh so this uh is basically
the the idea of a Newton's method uh and
then I will try
to write down the the keys
right
yeah so remember our goal is to find the
fix Point uh which
is
larger x equals to
FX so here again f is a is this Vector
function from R2 the N to some saring to
the N to the suar to the N right and
then if we rewrite this a little bit
we're really just finding the solution
to uh to this other G of X defined to be
FX minus
X so we're finding the zero for for this
for this function over here right and
then so the newon method goes like this
so we start as uh at some X
zero and then uh for every step we take
a first order approximation of our
function G uh so we have a uh you know
this is
GXT plus G Prime
XT uh times uh
X right and then over here uh once again
G is a vector function so this is
basically the d opian uh of of the of
the G
function uh and then we set uh x t t
plus one uh to be the solution of uh of
this this
thing uh
[Music]
DX and if we re rearrange it a little
bit uh we get uh uh X
yeah so this is the the Newton method
over real numbers which is
which works fine and then for us there
are a few uh issues we need to fix so
because we're working with Samar Rings
uh we don't really have a notion of
minus we don't really have a motion
notion of uh of inverse and we don't
have notion of
derivative so uh so we we're going to
Define this uh so that this algorithm
still works for for the saring
case uh and then the way to do this uh
is actually so I I think uh for the
details let's let's work it out in the
afternoon uh but really for the
derivative uh we just take kind of the
uh the
derivative using the algebra rules right
so so we have the uh you know the chain
rule for uh uh for multiply and then for
derivative of a constant is zero so that
that happen to still work if we if we
work with s Rings right and then uh in
the general algorithm uh so so as at
each step we're going to compute this
derivative and then instead of taking
taking the difference we're going to
find the Delta uh such that X Plus XT
plus that Delta equals to let me write
down
so so for the
Delta going to have the property of x t
plus
Delta equals to F of
XT so we can find any Delta with this
property so for example when when plus
is it poent we can just simply use f of
XT for for the Delta right and it's it
still helps because we have fewer
iterations of applying F in that case
right uh so so that's uh that's
derivative and and minus for the inverse
case uh instead of uh just inverting the
uh uh the the expression here uh we're
going to use the closure operation to
computed inverse so that was a few
slides ago I showed you that we can
compute this notion of in inverse with
the closure operation and then we're not
going to get exactly the inverse because
uh as D pointed pointed out we we're
we're dealing with Summer Rings uh but
uh
the when we compute the uh the closure
like that that give us uh an expression
that basically satisfy this equation
right so so for all of that there's a
lot of detail I guess we have a lot to
talk about in the
afternoon yeah and then so uh so some
other properties we we need to we need
to check is that we have this definition
of of derivative just from the algebraic
rules from calculus and how do we know
that is uh it works how do we know that
it actually respects uh the summary
semantics of of a program so the only
thing it really need to satisfy is is
this this inequality right so we say
that for any s function f if FX plus the
deriva of x times any any number any
other seman Z it needs to be less than
equal to you know F applied to X Plus z
uh and then we can we can see that that
holds for our definition of
derivative so what what notion of
inequality do you
use ah so uh so for any summary there's
a natural order which means that uh a
number is less than something else if
that number plus something is so uh let
me write it out
so yeah so for naturally aled sem is
it's defined like this yeah so that is
the Restriction that is needed for
applying method to they need to be
naturally and I believe uh every close
saring is semi naturally uh naturally
ordered okay
just I see I see yeah so so both it
needs to be both closed and naturally
ordered
yeah okay so I think this is a proof but
we can do it as a homework uh and then
for this Delta the question is that how
how can we pick this Delta that that
magically satisfy this property and we
can look into do that more in the
afternoon uh and then as another
exercise so we can try to evaluate uh
this nonlinear program using newon newon
method just as example to see how it
works
concretely uh okay yeah so I think we
have a few minutes for for questions if
we have
[Applause]
any
yeah so I mean just briefly if you can I
would love to get some sort of intuition
for like what is this Computing on a
simple program like shortest path to
reachability like for naive or semi
naive valuation I can state it very
easily like iteration wise like all the
one pads and the two pads and the three
pads and un go together like load to
have all the paths yeah right is can you
can you do something like that for for
this yeah so this example will will will
kind of show that and then another way
to think of this that so we're really is
uh you know when you when you have a
nonlinear program we're just really
really just fixing one of these to be
constant and then we run the program an
convergence and then we kind of
alternate between them
yeah
yeah so one one question I have about
this method is you're somehow comparing
different things right because in the
clean
iteration it's iteration is just a
computation of the fix Point yeah here
it's iteration of your newon method is
actually a fix Point
computation right so if you count the
total number of duration as fix points
in the one you you're multiplying the
number of like M iterations times the
times you need per fix point in your I
see yeah so uh yeah so you're saying
that the total work might might be
larger and it's true um so what I want
to understand but I I think I don't
understand is the way that make sense to
do that right yeah you need to argue
that the cost of your of your linear fix
point is actually going to be sipping
enough
that do you have like any thoughts about
that or yeah so one example is that uh
when the graph is reducible then we have
linear algorithm to compute the inner
fix point right so in that case uh I
think there are cases where Newton is
actually if we count total work is
faster and then another another idea
says maybe the inner fix point is easier
to parallelize so true yeah okay
so
yes so in that case we basically reduce
to the work versus depth tradeoff right
so it's it's easier
paralyzable yeah par is so another we
had an application in our
2014 paper on ciruit for data loog
so there is a COR
of all results that actually tells you
that there only a limited number of
iterations that give you under certain
conditions the fix
Point whichever way you obtained it and
actually for us for certain sings that
allowed us to prove that there exist um
circuits uh of poal
size for certain
problem yeah for certain for certain
problem like thean
Expressions perhaps more interestingly
something called the ABS pols and so but
so so that's you wanted an
application but I mean that has
nothing do with Newton right the
cleaning Newton uh it uses a corollary
of of the fact that you get to the fix
point after a certain number of
iterations of clean iterations
notations
cations I don't think you looked at
Newton iteration in that paper we used
the we use the theorem I think we didn't
use
the this is a a 16 2016
paper
okay okay let's take a five minutes
break and
[Applause]
then